[Musik]
silvan hat krebs
aber heute ist für den fünfjährigen ein
guter tag
nach neun monaten chemotherapie sagt der
arzt endlich das was alle hören wollen
casey war sie fertig ist ganz gut aus ja
und jetzt kommt dann wieder ganz normal
aufbauen und von den problemen
gate stack das thema nun auch noch von
corriere dass der bislang noch das
okay
das ist die familie meiner jüngsten
schwester irmela sie ist freischaffende
hebamme wolfgang ist physiklehrer lisa
barros und florin gehen die volksschule
silvan der jüngste in den kindergarten
eine ganz normale chaotische familie die
krebsdiagnose hat schlagartig alles
verändert
[Musik]
die krankheit bringt die ganze familie
durcheinander auch mich als tante wir
reden viel und beschließen dass ich sie
mit der kamera auf diesem unbekannten
weg begleitet eine gratwanderung
was machen wir wenn es ihm plötzlich
schlecht geht aber wir sind überzeugt
dass es uns und anderen helfen kann über
die krankheit zu reden
[Musik]
das drama begann im august 2011 bei
silbern fand man einen großen tumor an
der niere wir wussten noch nicht wie
bösartig dieser ist dabei hat es silvan
zuerst nur ein bisschen bauchweh
[Musik]
ja was denn die euro-zone ganzes kinder
spielt da eine
chance realisiert und bedachte auch in
buchen und
merkt da wächst
für jede behandlung wie zb blutentnahme
bekommt silbern eine perle auch für die
chemotherapie
am nächsten tag wird er operiert das
findet sie waren vor allem spannend die
angst der eltern spürt der fünfjährige
noch nicht
prozent ist er seine zuhörer
musiken wir gut
gespielt wie 20 100 essen
und decken erheben ausgeharrt hat einen
80 prozent und dass die anderen 20 sind
das wissen wir gar nicht zurück
damit sie mal vorher zu und hoffen
hoffnung ein strapaziertes wort wird
plötzlich so gegenwärtig und die
sehnsucht nach einer guten prognose
drängt sich ins leben der ganzen familie
in abstatt diagnose nämlich schlimm
stück sich der moment und es mit
selektierten hause können okay serie hat
humor
hab ich kann dadurch sind
die beiden haben vier kinder ich besuche
silber 13 geschwister zu hause meine
nichte und die beiden neffen müssen
damit leben dass ihre eltern sich moment
intensiv um den jüngsten bruder kümmert
zellwand krankheit betrifft die ganze
familie auch lisa florin und marus sind
in diesen strudel des tumors
hineingezogen worden versuchen jedoch
den alltag zu leben
der neunjährige florian muss schon jetzt
tapfer sein
oder unterhalt fast immer wieder mal
vor hinter
der stadt seien derart hoch der apparat
unterhaltsamer süßes gefühl mein
geschäft lotsen jetzt erst recht und ist
achter film
passt kürbis mit dem streak warschau
will halt
mal schauten rechnet will es ja und ich
denke nervt sie sich schneller und da
direkt in den hof
lisa ist 14 und die älteste der
geschwister im moment konzentriert sie
sich auf die kante prüfung das lenkt sie
ab von den sorgen sagt sie also ich bin
ja auch schon krank sagt es ein tumor
ich aber
die heilige sind und dass man immer
machen nach aus operieren das jetzt
wieder gut wie vorher und
halten mit großvater hat automaker und
ich gestorben bin ich ja schon reif
verschenken
der zwölfjährige maurus liebt es auf dem
wasser zu sein er spürt dass die eltern
anders sind als vor silvan krankheit
ich habe schon mein gesprochen dass es
bücher
so zeigen ziel waren dass sie sich
ruhig sind einfach aber
so direkt
berührt mich an ich merke einfach aber
vor allem auf den mangel halt
das macht
aber so richtig konkret
ist mir auf der mir jetzt wo etwas er
hat mama papa obwohl ich ein 18 meter
da geht es nicht so das ist
im nachhinein
ja
der ist so matschie
wer auf den ohren
aber nicht viel
[Musik]
der tag der operation im kinderspital
zürich
[Musik]
er mahnt wolfgang sind seit dem frühen
morgen hier siege trauen sich nicht das
spital zu verlassen obwohl sie wissen
dass die operation noch ein paar stunden
dauern wird
wir dürfen mit der kamera im
operationssaal dabei sein meine
schwester sagt sie finde es schön wenn
ich als tante wenigstens insolvenz nahe
sei
[Musik]
ich bekomme weiche knie als ich ihn so
liegen sehe den kleinen wicht aber mir
hilft es auch dabei zu sein
kaum zu glauben dass in dem kleinen
körper ein so großer tumor gewachsen ist
die befallenen ihre muss auch entfernt
werden
es sind lange fünf stunden im
operationssaal
grüezi und hallo
[Musik]
operation nicht mitgemacht ich sehe gute
haben begründet in ihrer nähe wie es
jetzt mit kindern die luft kühlt aber
dennoch ist der größte ist die groß sind
sie
haben
und jetzt tun da ist eigentlich alles
was man sehen kann ich einfach von auge
gesehen was was irgendwie ein knoten
konto liter das haben wir alles zu sagt
aber dass ich sehr häufig nicht eine
quasi auf zellulärer war vollständig
entfernt sich dass ich praktisch oder
häufig nicht so der fall und das
eingeführte gründlich sowie ohnehin
lässt sich
wohl auch immer therapie machen findet
er das mit den drogen
sich definitiv so das nicht irgendwie
wollte das gericht nicht
so habe steht ja unser serviceteam
verankert was habt ihr
wirklich gut und
was man heute als ist ein herz schenken
ja aber dass ich jetzt
vertagt
[Musik]
das
als katholik speicher gemacht was mir
ein bericht über das ist alles gut
gegangen hat im operation
sie haben mir für seine unterstützung
alles quatsch aus unterseen war nicht
jetzt wieder verkürzt und zwischendecken
es passiert was nicht hat sich alles gut
so wie das bei solchen tarif also das
wüssten heute
[Musik]
michael
sommer
[Musik]
meine schwester ist tag und nacht bei
ihrem jüngsten kind im kinderspital geht
das sie sagt es sei als ob sie in einer
art blase leben würde die welt draußen
weit weg
die geschwister besuchen nicht nur dem
bruder sondern auch ihre mama die fehlt
ihnen
[Applaus]
nicht nur dass hier habt ihr die gäste
bedeutete
[Gelächter]
noch wissen wir alle nicht dass sie noch
viele viele tage und nächte im spital
verbringen werden
ein paar wochen später drüben dunkle
wolken die hoffnung der krebs ist viel
aggressiver als vermutet
[Musik]
meine schwester ist fix und fertig aber
silvan freut sich wenn wir mit der
kamera kommen auf meine frage wie es ihm
geht diktiert er seine mutter diesen
zettel
bestrahlt das ist für 70 gleichzeitig
das heißt immer wieder für jeweils drei
tage ins kinderspital
damit sie wissen was mit ihrem bruder
während der chemotherapie jeweils
passiert sind sie heute an den
geschwister nachmittag im kinderspital
eingeladen
die drei großen sind jetzt öfters als
sonst auf sich gestellt silvan krankheit
beeinflusst auch hier leben
war das mama sie waren weggeschüttet ich
meinen
sie dazu
davon wiederum
untereinander reden sie kaum über die
krankheit ihres bruders aber ab und zu
kommen vor dem einschlafen ein paar
tränen
wolfgang ist so oft wie möglich bei den
kindern er hat ein teilpensum als lehrer
und wird von seiner schule mit viel
verständnis von neben aufgaben entlastet
[Musik]
dann los
und wenn
[Musik]
ja
was machen das sagen dass gott
[Musik]
florians rezept ist backen
seine schokoladenkuchen kennen schon
fast alle auf der krebs abteilung im
kinderspital
florin findet es nicht erwähnenswert
aber ich weiß dass er wenn möglich jeden
tag nach der schule zu seinem kleinen
bruder nach zürich ins spital fährt ganz
alleine
[Musik]
einmal in der woche geht florin mit
einem freund zur trommel probe das hilft
ihm seine manchmal auftauchende wut ein
bisschen zu kanalisieren
florin hat seiner trommel lehrerin
sofort davon erzählt dass sein bruder
krebs hat
[Musik]
[Applaus]
dass irgendwo was
[Musik]
er macht und
begeisterung seine partei und er darauf
einfach so
[Musik]
aber er soll einfach für sie und es ist
ein profi ich also wo ihm gehört oder
nicht man teile mit anderen schuldig
[Musik]
wieder einmal müssen silvan und seine
mama für die chemotherapie drei tage auf
den planeten onko wie sie es nennen im
kinderspital
silbern ist frustriert der tumor ist weg
und immer nach der chemo fühlte sich
schlecht das versteht nicht dass
du
ja
das
ist aber
okay
situation
also
es ist so eine ausnahmesituation für ihn
stark sitzung überhaupt das ganze über
sich
anständig bislang
oft
bestehe aber auch in betracht ziehen
und wenn bernd weiß ich
[Musik]
nur für schwimmer ist erstickt oder
kleiner schlichtweg zu erzielen ist
meine pflicht im wasser mampfen sicher
nicht und lass dir eines sagen schwimmen
ii mit vollem magen
die badegäste rasten aus hey
besserwisser geh nach hause manch ein
team klar zu hassen
[Musik]
die nächte sind lang im kinderspital
wenn er mal nicht schlafen kann hfc im
internet dabei hat sie die homepage von
malin gefunden malin ist ein mädchen
dessen bruder an krebs gestorben ist sie
schreiben sich oft
an einem sonntag beschließen wir malin
und ihre familie kennenzulernen und
fahren zu ihnen die geschwister wollen
mit kommen
ein halbes jahr liegen sie nun schon mit
ihrer geschichte von silvan krankheit
und sind froh dass sie sich mit jemandem
austauschen können der ähnliches erlebt
hat natürlich hat flurin wieder gebacken
malin ist zehn jahre alt und hat
jahrelang vergeblich kinder gesucht die
wie sie ein krankes geschwister haben
ihr bruder till hatte einen hirntumore
und musste auch bei ihren vier jahren
immer wieder zur chemie ins kinderspital
nun ist es ein jahr her seit er
gestorben ist es ist erstaunlich dass
silvan geschwister trotz dieser
traurigen geschichte mitgekommen sind
also
der vitrine oder
ich habe
praktisch
türen auf und lässt ihnen
sterbe
ich weiß es nicht was immer noch etwas
das hat viel weniger miete sielemann
oder und das hat er natürlich noch da
gelang umdrehen also seitdem jene player
gegen mainz konzipiert
spielt ein lässiges müssen die gruppe
[Musik]
an den start die erzieherin
[Gelächter]
auch
ohne eine spur
und macht sich lustig
[Musik]
glatter kraft
aber will ich so liebe ich
habe mich morgen auf wird also nicht
mehr hätte woche in kraft das allein
[Applaus]
war ich da
groß
ist die blättchen also dagegen
ein paar wochen später jetzt im
nachhinein es ist super super
sich einmieten und chatte wenn sven
sorgt sie könnte mit malin schrieben sie
weiß sie versteht sie die frage genauer
und und ich habe wirklich ein super
kontakt so kerstin zu die großmutter und
möglichem regen austausch
als nötig nur die seelenverwandtschaft
aber schon ich bin ja eine
geschichte wo verbindet und mehr müsse
der bisserl was geht und sie wären das
will
viel schneller verstanden den ort
als versierter ewig keine in ganz kurzer
zeit
[Musik]
zwischendurch ist planmäßig schlacht
weiß nie wie im herbst im moment kümmert
mit massa
executive officer wird eine eigentlich
los ist aber dass die feuchter als
mathematiker weiß ich selbst
für die statistik
medizinisch hat die zkb tätig
[Musik]
katri drucker schicken neuen andere wald
und tod und für risiken für ihn los ist
abstrakt konzept oder anders fast wie
mir das fast
nur medial
rollenspiel und abo modell ist tot
vor allem preise
hat wie die nyt august noch einmal
wusste dass
das wäre anders wenn
es das logo der seelen
dorf griechischen ski meiner wut und
jetzt kommt man schnell den kinski und
ich habe mit österreich
ist sowieso und die antwort ich
glaube das klingt ganz gut so wir
miteinander immer mal wieder etwas
machen das thema zumal wie andere
tanz show kinokassen und
verschiedener lüth von der kollegin in
der schule oder von acht arbeitern traf
ausspruch ich mit den anderen
geschwister die parks die partie
lisa die älteste packt es mit ehrgeiz
ich begleite sie heute in die
kletterhalle hier verbringt sie jede
freie minute
[Musik]
lisa ist das einzige mädchen in der
gruppe der sogenannten hard rocker auch
sieben monate nach der diagnose hat sie
noch niemandem hier erzählt dass ihr
bruder krebs hat
[Musik]
manchmal sind die blutwerte von silvan
so schlecht dass er maler und der kleine
vom kinderspital wieder nach hause
geschickt werden das heißt die
chemotherapie wird verschoben
[Musik]
also das mit aussehen dass plötzlich weg
wir sind dann die andere zimmermann zwar
sich sehr unterschiedlich dass ich kaum
einschätzbar 70 jetzt sucht im alter
entsprechen
silvan ist und die florianis so
viel
es ist
schon immer wieder so land bekam was ich
eigentlich becker und die märchenspiele
mit eurem so lange willst bevor diese
schriften ja
das hab ich
den irak gestresst ein bisschen lustig
berater und die ganze woche managed
sondierungen wolfgang
holst also wie war es mehr stress ich
sehe wohl ihre geschäfte so viel und
erzieherin widerwillig metall bin ich
irgendwie
hast du denn machen wir es mal so ich
bin halt
machen
das ist nun mal sehr gut
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der zwölfte april silvan ist heute sechs
jahre alt geworden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
obwohl er in den letzten wochen fast nie
mehr in den kindergarten ging weil er
sich zu schwach fühlte sind seine
spanien gekommen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wenn dir drin kreativ ist und es hat
ehrensache dass florin den kuchen
gebacken hat
[Musik]
am morgen war selber noch in der
kontrolle über la will mir kurz erzählen
wie es war
also wirklich auf den weg gekriegt und
gesagt kann ich nicht
akzeptieren
das nicht so klar als ossi es ist nicht
sicher war das einfach nicht
[Musik]
sagt mario das kann nicht
wahr sein grossvater gestorben ist
ja
[Musik]
der kindergeburtstag mit schatzsuche und
allem drum und dran ist in vollem gange
so habe ich ein bisschen zeit mit lisa
alleine
[Musik]
also ohne bugs hat eine simple er wird
auch sap sap info show gefragt ja
überwiegend gute chance und
denkt
aber ich denke
dass nicht dass
das in zukunft nicht das hofft natürlich
pisa oder haschisch mit der hand trend
dann co ja
christa brach mir
[Musik]
dort um nicht damit dass sie auch mal
erkannt wenn ich bin schon gemerkt sich
eigentlich an also sich sehr viel
größeren familie ist
und gleich wenigsten andere familie
andere geschichte und
ich merke es wichtig dass man etwas mit
dem projekt wie sich irgendwelches
tabuthema sie scannt alle tage gleich
mit um es gibt familie war das messopfer
sich macht und nichts wie groß sie kennt
wir gehen jetzt kennt halt sehr robust
und
ja ich kann einfach es ist wichtig dass
man das thematisiert
[Musik]
so steigend lich als familie zum teil
erreicht abkapselt ich also oder habit
erhält weiterhin wie es nicht getraut
zum verein gehört wie es nicht wisse wie
sich
[Musik]
gute nachrichten helfen in diesen zeiten
die freude ist groß kerstin die mutter
von malin ist wieder schwanger diesmal
besuche ich sie alleine die geschwister
von silvan waren in der zwischenzeit
schon mehrmals da
[Musik]
bei der vorsorgeuntersuchung haben sie
gesehen dass es ein mädchen wird
[Musik]
das gar nicht gedanken gemacht was wir
möchten ist so viel mut braucht es
überhaupt wagen und warum es dann noch
eine fordern ein kleines kreuz und malin
head on the physics klappt einfach
sehr konzentriert und da ich im himmel
und eine schwester und nicht das hat man
immer auch formen schlechtere werk das
so ich glaube
ich möchte hier gehen ich glaube es ist
nun mal daran glauben dass man
hätte mit zwei alte pony motor nicht nur
am kühlsystem
aber es muss immer er sie braucht ja am
anfang nicht unbedingt großes thema
ist ein
fachlich vor ihm und vor ihre und
nachher
das ist vor ihm und das ist tauss reiter
da
für sie
noch
[Musik]
zehn monate nach der krebsdiagnose von
silvan hat seine schwester lisa die
prüfung bestanden seine brüder maurus
und florin waren erfolgreich an den kanu
schweizer meisterschaften und silvan hat
heute die letzte chemo hinter sich das
alles wollen sie feiern und haben
kerstin und malin dazu eingeladen und
wir sind ein letztes mal mit der kamera
dar
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
florin ist glücklich den grund dafür
wieder mal ihn unbedingt zeigen
diese geschichte zu filmen war für uns
alle eine gratwanderung wir wünschen
dass es vielleicht anderen geschwistern
eltern tanken oder gratis lief über das
schlimme zu reden und nicht zu
verzweifeln und mut macht nachzufragen
auch bei den geschwistern immer wieder
passiert ist
[Musik]
das war im letzten juni was wir in
diesem moment nicht wussten nach den
sommerferien kam der krebs zurück
schlimmer als zuvor wieder eine große
operation und heftige chemotherapie und
bestrahlung folgten doch es kamen auch
gute nachrichten
heute geht es hilfen gut es bleiben die
hoffnung und die angst vor jeder
nächsten kontrolle aber auch die freude
über jeden geschenkten tag
[Musik]